مؤمن اذا استهدافات اسرائيليه للفلسطينيين
المحاصرين داخل المستشفيات ماذا في اخر
الانباء التي توفرت عن الوضع في مستشفى
ناصر وايضا اخر تحديثات الاوضاع الميدانيه
عموما نعم السي اخر التطورات الميدانيه هي
غاره جويه اسرائيليه استهدفت منزلا لعائله
الزريعي عند مدخل شارع البيئه في مدينه
دير البلح وسط القطاع ادت هذه الغاره الى
اصابه عدد من سكان هذا المنزل فيما تعمل
حاليا فرق الاسعاف وايضا الدفاع المدني
لانتشال جثامين شهداء وانقاذ حياه الجرحى
ونقلهم الى مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في
المدينه الغاره الاسرائيليه دمرت هذا
المنزل على رؤوس ساكنيه ووصفت هذه الغاره
بالعنيف نتيجه استهداف هذا المنزل بعدد من
الصواريخ الحربيه التي اطلقتها طائرات جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الى جانب ايضا قبل
قليل قصف اسرائيلي بعدد من الصواريخ
استهدف مخيمي البريج والمغازي في وسط
القطاع ايضا في مدينه خانيونس تزداد
الامور سوءا تحديدا داخل مجمع ناصر الطبي
الذي يؤوي نحو 10 الا نازح بالاضافه الى
المئات من الجرحى والمرضى والكوادر الطبيه
مع تعمد قناصه جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بين الفينه والاخرى اطلاق الاعيره الناريه
والرصاص الحي وبشكل مباشر على مباني مجمع
ناصر الطبي ما ادى الى ارتقاء شهيد
بالاضافه الى وجود عدد من الاصابات سبقه
ايضا اطلاق نار من قبل قناص جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي استهدف غرفه العمليات قسم
العمليات في مجمع ناصر الطبي ما ادى الى
اصابه احد الممرضين بعيار ناري بالصدر
وحالته الجراحيه خطيره الى جانب ايضا تعمد
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
اعطاب خزانات المياه الرئيسيه لمجمع ناصر
الطبي وعدم تمكن الفنيين من الخروج الى
اعلى مبنى مجمع ناصر الطبي لاصلاح هذا
الخلل الامر الذي يؤدي الى شح كبير في
المياه وهو مورد مهم جدا خاصه ان المئات
من النازحين الذين يتواجدون في مراكز
الايواء المحيطه ب مجمع ناصر الطبي خاطروا
بحياتهم هذا اليوم لوصول الى مجمع ناصر
الطبي للحصول على المياه ما ادى الى
ارتقاء سبعه منهم برصاص قناصه جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الى جانب ايضا ان
دبابات وجرافات جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
دمرت وهدمت اسوار مدرسه الامل التي تؤوي
النازحين وايضا هناك قصف واطلاق ناريه
كثيفه في محيط مستشفى الامل التابع لجمعيه
الهلال الاحمر و مع نفاذ مخزون الاكسجين
الامر الذي يهدد حياه العشرات من المرضى
والجرحى داخل هذا المستشفى الى جانب تحذير
الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني من نفاذ الوقود
خلال اربعه ايام ومطالبته المجتمع الدولي
بضروره الضغط على سلطات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لايصال وادخال الاكسجين
والوقود والمستلزمات
الطبيه ليتمكن مستشفى الامل من العمل في
ظل الحصار المطبق والشديد الذي تفرض منذ
اكثر من اسبوعين قوات جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في تلك المنطقه الى جانب ايضا
القصف المدفعي الاسرائيلي الذي يطال مدارس
النازحين في محيط مجمع ناصر الطبي وايضا
منطقه الحوز وبلوك جيم في مخيم خان يونس
الامر الذي ادى الى حق اضرار ماديه في
المنازل المستهدفه وايضا اشتعال النيران
والحرائق فيها نتيجه القصف المدفعي
الاسرائيلي الى جانب الغارات الجويه التي
نسفت هذا اليوم عدد من المربعات السكنيه
في وسط وشرق وايضا الى الشمال الغربي من
مدينه خن يونس اشكرك مراسله مؤمن الشرافي
حدثتنا من المستشفى الكويتي في رفح